hello my name is eva dyer and i'm a
professor at georgia tech and emory
university
today i will tell you about exciting new
work from my lab in
being able to leverage new tools that
are
being used in different areas of machine
learning called self-supervised learning
and leveraging these self-supervised
learning techniques to build
representations of neural activity
all right
so i'll start off just by acknowledging
the many individuals across many
institutions that made this work
possible
my folks in the nerds lab at georgia
tech on the left
and this work that i'll describe was
really spearheaded by mehdi azabu
as well as our collaborators at washu st
louis
at deepmind and johns hopkins apl and
then i'd also like to acknowledge our
sponsors including nih
and the theory methods and models
program
all right
so
the underlying motivation of the work
that i'll describe today is um driven by
you know a pervasive question in in
neuroscience
that is you know given
some observations of many neurons in the
brain how can we take that information
how can we take those measurements and
build meaningful representations of
neural activity that allow us to get a
lens into the underlying behavior or
task or intent that the animal or
individual is you know sort of
representing in their brain
and this is a really hard problem in
general uh there's many different
approaches that have been taken to build
representations but with that
we still are facing a number of
challenges that have to do with the
stability
and the sort of utility of these
representations and often neural states
or activity patterns of the brain will
actually shift over time or when we come
in and record at a new day we'll have
access to a different subset of neurons
and so
these different sources of variability
do make it hard to build a
representation and then use it and carry
it forward in savory machine interfaces
or other downstream applications
so
we were really interested in whether or
not we could use new tools that are
really um being established in computer
vision and graphs and other areas of
machine learning we are interested in
whether or not we could leverage these
new state-of-the-art tools in a neural
domain in order to solve the problem
that i describe which is building
representations of neural activity and
so
um you know the first question or just
i'll start by describing what
self-supervised learning is and what are
the principles underlying it and then
from there kind of describe how we can
use these same general principle ideas
and apply them within neuroscience so
first what are the principles underlying
self-supervised learning
unlike other methods for building
representations that rely on essentially
reconstruction or generating patterns of
activity that resemble the inputs the
idea behind ssl self-supervised learning
i'll just call it ssl
is to essentially take an input so in
our case we'll we'll think about a
collection of activity of neurons and
that will represent a brain state
um but what i'm showing here is just a
sort of illustrative example is you know
a
case where we have an image
and from that sample or that image the
idea is that we'll basically generate
through some transformations two
different views of that same underlying
sample or image and um what i'm showing
here on the right is a kind of
demonstration of this so you know we
have a picture of a cat and then we're
applying two different
transformations um to create different
views of the same cat right either
changing the color
or um in the bottom example zooming in
you know and cropping so that we have
a different um
a different view of
of the same cap as i said and so the
idea is to basically take those
different views and then learn a
representation um often with a neural
network
that basically is trying to maximize the
similarity
or minimize the distance between
the embedding of these different views
in the latent space of the neural
network and so
um as i you know outline here the
approaches create augmentations and then
pass them through and and try to
maximize similarity and really
the intuition behind that is if we give
the neural network really diverse views
of something with the same underlying
semantics and we can learn a
representation in this way then we can
basically get rid of all of the other
nuisance variables or or other sources
of variability that aren't essential to
the underlying task which in this case
would be to recognize cats from dogs or
other um other images
and um
and so
the set of transformations or
augmentations that we apply
we will build in different types of
invariants into the representation
so
you know as i sort of alluded to
um
self-supervised learning methods are you
know providing very impressive
performance on a number of complex tasks
in natural images and in computer vision
and now over the past um year
these methods have started to actually
approach
um the performance of supervised methods
that are trained end-to-end whereas you
know in this case as as i described it
um we do need some information about the
augmentations that we apply but the
actual method itself is a fully
unsupervised representation learning
method and so this is an exciting new
advance in the field to show that
unsupervised approaches can really
provide these rich features that will
rival the performance of supervised
methods
so
a core
question that we have to ask right is
how are these views
of a sample generated right because that
will um be critical to the sorts of um
representations that we build and so
in vision
uh as i sort of said before the
intuition is that we're interested in
applying some transformation that will
still keep the essence of the cat or the
dog in this case so not changing the
semantics um but providing these you
know really diverse pictures of the same
object
and in in images we have we know of
really rich
augmentations or transformation classes
that will
um solve this task right of capturing
underlying semantics while also
providing pixel level content that's you
know very different
and um
and so when you have these rich
augmentation classes for instance in
vision
um you can as i showed before achieve
these really
state of the art
perform or you know
performance right when you have rich
enough augmentations that you're
building in but in new domains really
understanding what the right
augmentations to apply
r is is challenging and it's not very
well characterized yet and so when we
set out to
you know
think about how these ideas could be
applied within neuroscience
we started with some kind of you know
core principles that are guided um you
know as the topic of this workshop
guided by theory
and in particular we sort of
look to or have insights from predictive
coding models which have been leveraged
um extensively in neuroscience and so
the first idea is okay we want to find
something that is that should have
shared or similar semantics to the the
brain state or the the sample that we're
interested in augmenting
um and so how we can do that is first by
using just a sort of temporal
consistency or the fact that if i'm you
know uh as i'm showing here in the
picture so x would be the activity or
the firing rate of multiple neurons
stacked into a vector and that's now um
the brain state vector or observation
that we're interested in and then when
we
build a sort of augmentation what we're
interested in doing is figuring out um
the the common or the shared information
between two neighboring points in time
right and so x and x prime could be just
defined as either you know some forward
steps or backward steps or some random
um view that's within a local window in
time um and so that gives us at least an
initial um idea of how we might be able
to map this idea of information
maximization based learning into a
neural framework
but we were interested in whether or not
we could actually go further than just
looking very local in time right because
ideally
because we don't know the right
transformations to apply to create
augmentation
ideally we might be able to look from
within the data set directly to figure
out what are the sources of variability
that we need to build in variance to and
as i described at the beginning one of
the challenges that we find is that
neural activity patterns do drift so
being able to link
um and and and learn representations
across non-local or you know kind of
temporally distinct points in time would
also be a really powerful strategy so
um really the goal
is to build a framework where we can
leverage the diversity within our neural
activity or within our data
to solve this um augmentation or self
self-supervised learning task
so as i said first we'll look locally
and then um as we start to build a
representation that is sort of stable
in time really our goal is to go beyond
just those local views
and to start to
group similar experiences or similar
brain states that might not be
closed in time but but should have
shared or similar semantics and so
in order to achieve this sort of
um
this
this goal right of having both this
predictive coding framework that works
on a local but also non-local
scale we developed a new self-supervised
learning approach
that's general so can be applied to
images and we're also interested in
applying it now to graphs but as i
described was really motivated and
driven by this neuroscientific
application and this need to di create
diverse augmentations of data when
we otherwise might not know how to apply
them directly
so
which is called mind your own view or
meow
and we build this framework on top of a
sort of existing predictive engine that
i showed at the beginning that's you
know really achieving these um soda or
state-of-the-art performance in ml but
hadn't none of these methods have been
applied within neural activity or neural
populations and so
we start with this baseline framework
that i showed at the beginning where we
you know can create augmentations
through these transformations
pass it through a network and then
essentially try to minimize a normalized
euclidean distance between these
different transform views
and then in addition to that in addition
to this
term which in our neural example works
over these local and dropped out views
of neural activity so by masking certain
neurons and jittering um locally in time
and then in addition to that we build a
sort of cascaded architecture that you
know starts with those local predictions
and then adds in an additional branch
for these non-local predictions or in
the case of images we would actually
look from within the data set find
another
candidate view that is similar in the
representation space in the network and
then use that then as a positive
predictive target for this
self-supervised method and so here on
the bottom i'm just showing an example
of this where you know we're passing in
the same image of a cat we can transform
it or look locally
to create an augmentation and then we'll
basically try to look over a set of you
know other images or other samples find
the find the closest one or a near
neighbor in the representation space of
the network select that and then pass it
through the network in a similar way to
minimize or sorry maximize similarity
but now instead of having other examples
of the same cat we're leveraging the
fact that there are other pictures of
other cats that are similar to kind of
build a more unified
perspective on this and our loss is just
a mixture of this local and non-local
sort of term which i'm showing here over
on the right um and you can
trade off the sort of amount of local
versus non-local
okay
so
that's the sort of
overview of um this general approach for
self-supervised learning and now i will
dig into
the results and the application of this
idea in two different
settings in um in neuroscience and so
the first one is a slightly simpler task
or
a task where
an animal is trained to make reaching
movements
targets
there's um basically a cue that comes on
the screen and they'll make a reach so
standard center outreaching task we're
recording from neurons in the primary
motor cortex in this case
roughly about 100 to 200 neurons across
these different data sets and what i'm
showing here are
the results of essentially training this
neural network using this local
non-local
strategy in order to find
representations and then comparing with
other baselines
and
what we do is we
train the network in an unsupervised way
we basically freeze the the weights
and then the goal is to use the
representations to just form a linear
readout so only a single linear layer
that's appended to the representation to
to read out some um decoding information
so we're using the c coding task as a
way of understanding
how well
the reach direction in this case is
already being embedded within the the
neural uh the representations of the
neural activity so
um each group of bars is a different
data set we have two different days
from um two individuals so chewie and
mihi
and um comparing with an auto encoder
and simclear by also other um ssl
methods
and so
the take the take-home message here
would be that you know
not only does meow
the proposed approach that uses a
combination of local and non-local
augmentations you know provide a
significant improvement over these other
baseline approaches the other thing to
take away is that if we look at the
supervised performance so
um
the accuracy that we get when we test on
a held out chunk of time
on a supervised decoder trained on the
same task
what we find is that actually the ssl
approaches will often
outperform a supervised decoder which is
a really exciting result because it
shows us that there are
important forms of um regularization
and um
you know information that we're
embedding through these augmentations
that allow
um a neural network to perform better at
test time on held out data so we're
forming in some sense more stable
representations
that allow us to
decode this particular behavior
effectively
we can also
look at the
um the latent spaces or sort of
visualize the representations that are
being formed in this case and we find
consistently that
um by using our strategy we can preserve
more of the global structure of the task
so here showing results from meow
after applying um t-sne in this case to
find some low dimensional embeddings and
here we're finding that the kind of
overarc you know the the circular nature
of the task is being preserved within
the representation space whereas we
don't see that with some of the other
competing methods
um
here i'm just sort of showing
a number of the ablations that we
provide in the paper
which is out on archive
to kind of explore how
incorporating different sources of noise
or as i talked about before
um different amounts of dropout right
how how does that drop out or the
temporal jitter augmentations that i
described how does that impact the
overall performance in terms of first
building this stable and good
representation and what we find is that
consistently
um
both a combination of dropout and this
sort of local prediction that i
described is both of those things are
essential for building
meaningful
biases or regularization into the
network that allows us to then really
leverage this non-local structure
further with with meow
and these are just now kind of zooming
or looking at the representations of the
data in three dimensions and showing
that we can both preserve
the different reach directions which i'm
showing here over on the left where all
the different points are color coded
by the actual restriction we're showing
nice separability but in addition over
on the right i'm just showing that the
um the other aspect of this task which
you know is moving from a lower to high
high velocity in this outer portion of
the latent space
both of these aspects of the of the
behavior are being
captured in these in these neural
representations
formed by meow
okay
um so after establishing a method on a
number of different data sets in the um
in the macaque we then went on to apply
our approach to
free behavior so
um
in this case we have recordings from
different rodents i'll mainly talk about
well i have an example from the mouse
hippocampus on the right and also from
rat v1 and we're trying to expand this
into even more diverse brain regions and
really understand how well these sorts
of ideas generalize to different sorts
of behavior and different brain areas
um and so what i'm showing here now is
we apply
we apply approach and now we just read
out
through this linear layer we're going to
read out information about sleep state
so
here we're trying to decode rem from
non-rem from wake
across large 12-hour blocks of data so
this is while the animal is running
around in their cage and there's no
explicit
excuse me no explicit
training it's just free behavior
and so what we find or what we can you
know say is that drop out as an
augmentation
continues to be a powerful form of
regularization and we find that our
results overall hold in terms of you
know either outperforming or matching a
supervised decoder on this sleep task
where we only have three classes and so
it's a bit of an easier readout
and you know really just further
confirming that these ideas can be
applied in more diverse domains
what's interesting is that even though
our
behavioral labels are relatively coarse
right
being awake or being asleep um if we
actually look at the underlying
representations that are being formed by
meow in comparison to say just using the
raw firing rates or the raw data
even though the behavior is nicely
separable we get very high accuracies we
actually find that there's a lot more
going on under the hood a lot of
interesting sort of clustering and um
differences in in the representations
and so
we are interested in digging into that
further
and in the last few minutes i'll just
describe some of our preliminary results
which we're really excited about because
we see that you know this tool gives us
a way
of finding unique
um parts of the representation space
that seem to be linked to unique and
complex behaviors so
um just you know without being able to
go into this into too much depth and and
show all you um
we
developed a
tool that's sort of just an extension on
tensorboard where we can take the
representations learned by the network
zoom in on them and then get additional
behavioral readouts and see the position
um you know whether or not
meow is finding other points over
distant points uh or over
uh
i guess what i'm trying to describe it
here is the plot i can't show with my
cursor but on the upper
right hand side where it says selected
cluster and so basically the black lines
show
all of the points in time that the
network is sort of saying
are very similar in terms of the
underlying brain state that was present
and so we do find that
there are you know local
points in time of course where the
animal is doing similar things but then
the network will also link distant
points in time and and you know when we
go in and confirm we find that often the
the animal and the behavior is quite
similar so in this case just looking at
an example where we have water drinking
on the bottom our insets of of the video
um you know finding
clusters in the latent space that course
related to nest building or you know
kind of getting comfortable but not
sleeping so a quiet wake state
um being more active and playful and
moving with moving their box and other
objects
and um and so on and so forth so we're
starting to now um be able to leverage
the
unique
insights provided by self-supervised
methods and our approach in particular
meow and use that with these really
large untethered data sets to build um
insights into encoding in this case in
in hippocampus
that we're really excited about uh
you know
describing in terms of the
neuroscientific implications as well
all right and before i end i'll just
kind of quickly give a plug for some
related work
um where we've you know been able to
take this idea
of um
invariance-based learning with
self-supervised learning through meow
and
kind of combine that with a generative
modeling approach or variational
autoencoder and this is recent work i
have references here if you're
interested
called swap vae which essentially is
combining um
these self-supervised methods for neural
activity
along with a vae to kind of hopefully
get the best of both where you can see
the things that are you know kind of
stable
and common
across local views
while also having a full range of
variability
necessary to actually generate realistic
neural activity
and we are using this to
understand and try to build disentangled
representations
of neural activity
all right so um i'll go ahead and
conclude so in summary i um described
this new approach for ssl called mind
your own view
it's
i didn't describe the results in natural
images but we're finding that we can
compete with state-of-the-art methods in
cfar and tiny imagenet and some of these
other computer vision data sets
um
we described specifically the
application of meow to neural population
activities discuss what it means to form
augmentations of neural activity and
show that those work in both rodan and
macaque
and then also demonstrating that a
cross-sample prediction with meow often
beats this
supervised baseline
and finally just a little preview of
some work that we're doing where we're
trying to combine these ideas with
generative modeling approaches and um
showing that that can be used to sort of
disentangle
um
things like reach direction from the
actual dynamics
so
with that i will thank you so much for
your attention and um invite you to
check out some of the the code or some
of the other work that i presented on
either of the two links thank you so
much